all right it's time for audience
questions after a breaker of a couple of
weeks I've got some really good ones
this week and that we've been on fire
with these audience questions lately
just a lot of good ones coming in first
one is from surah who said hey how do
you guys handle people who start telling
you way too much about themselves or
their problems or just won't stop
talking to you so I'll sort of talk
focus on the first part because I've
talked I think the last time we did
audience questions there was a question
about how to get out of a conversation
that you don't want to be in or
something and I said at a business event
I will just ask for someone's card and
then that'll interrupt the conversation
while they grab the card and then I
immediately say nice to meet you and
then it's a good opportunity to walk
away in social situations it can be a
little tougher but I've had people who
are sort of like a too much information
type of thing and the thing is
culturally like in the u.s. it's seen as
weirder so after meeting someone briefly
to go into more detailed things about
your personal life health issues for
example or family problems
in Argentina where I was born it's way
more common that you're just talking to
the clerk at a clothing store and they
might start talking to you about a
health issue that they're having or
whatever so I think it's all sort of but
there's some arbitrary nature to it in
terms of what's expected in a particular
culture but I have experience for me the
problem isn't hearing about personal
things from people it's about where
there's really an expectation that we're
gonna have like a ten-second exchange
and then it just seems to go on and on
and on where the other person thinks
it's okay to just just kind of like be
having a conversation when it's not
really the right setting for it I will
usually just pull out my phone and
nobody really knows whether the phone
has vibrated or not right though even
though you didn't hear a ring the phone
might have vibrated so I'll just pull it
out and I'll put a finger up and say oh
you know I'm sorry I'm gonna have to
deal with this and then I can just step
away and very rarely will anyone be
offended by that and it's sort of a
victimless lie I find depends on the
situation but I often expect them to ask
for money at some certain point like if
you're in a city in your approached by
someone yeah and they start going on
this long spiel about how they have to
buy a train ticket to get home to the
significant other okay yes expects
alright they're obviously going to ask
for money at some point how do I get out
of this conversation before they waste
all that time doing that right but
that's like we're more specific in a in
a panhandling type situation you never
know when it's gonna be a panhandling
situation or not or you don't like it
could just want to talk let's assume
you're at a social gathering right and
you've been just introduced to someone
new and your mutual friend has walked
away to get a drink at the bar area or
something like that and you're left with
someone who goes you know it's really
tough but I've been having this
persistent rash and it's the weirdest
thing because I've taken benadryl and it
doesn't seem to be an allergic thing and
I've not been been bitten by any animal
or anything like that and it's just
every morning I get up and I you know I
shower and I do my thing and the rash
just keeps getting worse and worse and
you know what and I actually I would go
see a doctor but the thing is I don't
actually have health insurance right now
and you know it
it cost me 25 dollars that's when I
start to get skeptical that's when I
start thinking that they're going to try
to ask for money yeah well but I guess
the idea is if it's a social event what
do you do excuse yourself to the
bathroom I just try to not along I guess
and deal with it I mean I'm pretty blunt
about those sorts of things where I'll
just you know make clear that I want to
change the topic of conversation yeah or
that I'm just not it really interested
because clearly they're over sharing I
know people who say in these situations
they just say nothing wit because they
say listen if you don't engage in the
conversation the other person will stop
talking not true there are people who
will just continue they'll continue
talking even if you say nothing and
those who say hey that person was a
really good listener so I think it's
okay I think it's a victimless deception
to either say excuse me I have to visit
the restroom or pretend that your phone
just buzzed and that you've got to deal
with something on the phone I don't see
any problem with that it just seems like
if someone opens up a conversation with
you meeting you for the first time yeah
with a topic that's so personal to them
and something that would obviously
perturb you in some way or form they're
just not worth having in your network
you can see what I mean
they just don't seem to have the best
social skills one of the things that has
changed for me from my early 20s into my
mid to late 20s and then into my early
30s is in my early in mid 20s I was much
more willing to sort of continue to
associate and be around people and
relate to people that I didn't really
enjoy being around because I felt that
you know it's good to have the largest
possible network of people you're in
touch with or you know it's just if that
person is seen as cool or popular then I
should try to align myself with them at
whatever cost there is I don't care
about that anymore I have done
everything I can to sort of rid my
personal network of people that I find
to be either toxic or just not enjoyable
to be around because you know what life
is short and why am i bothering you know
what why why why tolerate it well you
say you get out you ask for business
cards to get out of those awkward
situations in a professional setting and
then it goes rash maybe just ask for a
phone number oh I do the same thing in a
personal I'd love to follow up - can you
give me your phone number I think it
would go to hear about that rash I was
that yeah tell me about the rash be a
text please